good morning John I wanted to make this
video for like 10 straight years and
then recently I had something happen to
me that made me feel like hey maybe I
shouldn't put stuff off especially if
it's easy stuff and so you have seen
that I have bought a lot of questionable
items and now I am boiling pasta but
also you read the title of the video so
you know what's about to happen ho
freaking Ho everybody we're eating buddy
the elf's special pasta now I've seen
other people on YouTube do this and they
often have tomato sauce involved but if
you look closely when buddy chooses to
make pasta his perfect way I don't see
any pasta sauce on there which is good
for me cuz I think that would make this
significantly worse that's Chester by
the way he's our new cat instead
actually this ain't that bad it's
basically just eating candy with noodles
to cut the sweetness except they're not
cutting the sweetness at all I bet if
there were like pretzels on it you have
any pretzels yeah the pretzels didn't
really help look ultimately this is bad
and it makes my tummy
hurt for the thumbnail John before I got
sick I thought that I had a pretty good
grasp on what life was for
but as soon as I got a little bit close
to the edge I was amazed by how quickly
I lost my grasp on that there's a pretty
strong like how are we sure that any of
this matters at all vibe to secular
mortality I think that's fair to say
real question here when I'm dead will
anyone have eaten that elf pasta because
I feel like no certainly no one who
exists will have had my experience of
eating that elf pasta also do I even
have that experience now and someday I
might forget that I had the elf pasta is
the person that ate that elf pasta in
that situation is that person dead then
because that memory no longer exists I'm
getting to an age where I see clips of
myself on the internet doing stuff that
I have no idea I did are all of the mes
that had the experiences that I've
forgotten dead already I know I'm
wearing a ho ho ho onesie right now but
there is no Perpetual postponement of
the mortality of any experience or any
individual or any species or any system
of living chemistry and now that I'm
looking at it even if there was I don't
think that would help me find meaning in
a universe that to my eye doesn't have
any any objective meaning or at least if
it does is unwilling to share it with us
I'm not saying you should eat elf pasta
all the time or ever in fact never do
this obviously just positionally I am
about as far from being an nihilist as
you can get like it's just not
compatible with my brain chemistry but I
do understand it a little bit more than
I used to now mortality is depressing
it's or it's like a big thing to
struggle with anyway but I do want to be
very clear that throughout all of it I
still very much wanted to be alive for
as long as possible if only because
things are interesting and I wanted to
keep seeing them like it kind of boiled
down to that which kind of brought me
back to a weird place where like maybe a
big part of the right thing to do is to
do what feels right like not
hedonistically not eat all the elf pasta
you can just like recognize that I'm an
animal that evolved to be in community
with other animals like me and do that I
have needs and wants for myself and for
others and I should strive to attain
those things even if I'm only one piece
of the striving even if I don't think
I'm ever going to achieve it even if I'm
not going to even see that tree Sprout
even if I'm just planting the seed and
being like I'm not going to be around to
see what happens with that but I'm doing
it like I'm just trying to move toward
the thing that I want because I am me
and I am a person and I am a human being
and I am a living organism not because I
want to change the universe but because
I want and I think wanting is good like
I want to want I think when you stop
wanting which I have gotten there that's
the that's the bad part I want to want
and like a lot of the job of the
Consciousness is to try and direct the
want to try and figure out what the
right wants are and I want so many
things like earlier today I wanted elf
pasta and then I got it and now I don't
want it ever again now we can move on to
some other stuff and we're going to do
some of those things in the next year
and in the year after that and then
eventually we'll all die but we'll be
wanting together John I will see you
next year bonus content number one
Christmas Eve I'm going to upload a
weird video to Vlog brothers so expect
that I'm curious what everybody's going
to think about it two I'm doing my
cancer standup in Southern California
there is some information on the shows
that are currently booked there will be
more shows being booked I'll let you
know about them when they go live